hello and welcome to the new world
review i'm grand line waifu and i am
here to tell you all the things i happen
to know about the characters in episodes
100 and 101
episodes 101 we made it 100
in yay me as i hmm
oh characters from episodes oh big
number
i learned from watching those episodes
and nothing
you'd better believe we have an octopus
featuring in today's review but when i
say octopus i mean octopus of doom
doom all hail are eight limbed overlords
who would genuinely take over the world
if there were more water and we would
welcome them
for they are wise anyway episode 100 and
we continue to follow kilwa
and gone through their individual
situations kilwa caught the attention of
simba and ko
and now he's being hunted down which
which makes sense because baby simba
pito told big simba
is he mufasan to stop the problem this
is the first time the first time
ever that we have seen kilauea genuinely
being killed so named because he's gonna
kill one hell of a lot of
bugs kilwa got to be impressive today we
got to see how kiwa interacts with
enemies and how his abilities as an
assassin combined with those he's
learned as a hunter and it's pretty
damn magnificent really all the
precision he had when he started the
exam
all the dangerous aspects of him when he
was at the start are now fully on
display in a way that we've never seen
them we've always seen little pieces of
killer being the assassin he is we've
seen
all those glances the sharpness that
arrives when he has an enemy in his
sights but we've never just seen him
using his raw ability without hesitation
or concern
because he's not looking after someone
or concerned about them and that makes
sense because i don't know
that we've ever seen anyone in this show
use every ounce of their abilities
unless they're about to die
have lost control of themselves or are
gone gone is the only one i think we've
seen who has reached the limit of their
abilities publicly and lived to tell of
it which may be why kilwa waits until
they've separated to use the full extent
of his
don't share don't tell keep your secret
gone doesn't do that god doesn't know
how beyond
that he was in a situation where if he
doesn't he'll die
there's the aspect to it that if you see
someone's full ability that might be the
last thing you see
and that's a good point actually because
we haven't seen anyone using the full
extent of their power but gone we don't
often go
into god's mind but we see everything he
has to give as a combat
conversely we're often in kilwa's mind
but not seeing what he can do as a
fighter
in this moment we couldn't be as far
into kilwa's mind as we wanted to be so
takashi had to bring in a narrator to
tell us what he was doing it's so rare
that we get mid-episode narration or at
least it's rare that i've noticed it
this far into an episode because takashi
seems to prefer to have
an observer note something about someone
rather than
something very far outside of all of all
of this highlights that kilwa is
entirely alone he's alone with his
thoughts and anyone observing him is an
enemy which brings
even more sharply into focus exactly
what's happening for him he had all his
standard thoughts but
why explain to himself what he's about
to do thinking about it in broad terms
was enough and then to slow it down and
drop the color so we could focus on form
and shape rather than the wounding
effect the flea bullet would have and
that
was beautifully composed speaking of
flea bullet okay
so we have a gun armed bug man did the
queen eat a gun because as much as the
idea of the fleas being shot is very
rule of cool
i.e cool idea let's do it i'm not sure
what animals such a bug could be
replicating and it felt like a cop-out
from such an inventive creative
yes it's a flesh suit but the octopus
steals bodies from others which means
the body has to exist and i just
liked the personality of the character
but it destroyed my immersion in the
world and a story to have something like
that appear
i don't know maybe he built a gun and
shoved it into his flea dispersing
ball sack tagashi has been so carefully
researched about most of the show and
generally carefully considered about the
world and its inhabitants and i feel
like the
idea could have been better thought out
there just needed to be an
out or a way to draw kiwa to water to
show off the effect the chimera ants had
on sea life
and the octopus the literal grumpy
octopus
he's cute i'll grant him that i was
gonna say more but i think that's all
that needs to be said right now it's a
cute idea and i accept that offering
gimme gone now how is gone getting on
without keewan well
gone's wandering in a random desert and
fraternizing with an enemy who's smarter
than he is
that's how gone's getting on why gon
would immediately trust the chameleon no
one knows but he has and that's all
there is to it right it's gone whether
he actually does believe chameleon guy
or not the chameleon guy let's call him
kamelon mel camellan who doesn't like
was caught off guard because
who would be stupid enough to do that he
found himself a brawny kid and now he
can use that brawny kid to his own ends
and if i'm entirely honest i feel like
i've
lost track of exactly what the story is
and why we're in a desert i
i somewhat understand what happened to
kilwa because he was following the story
but since i
watch only two episodes a week i don't
actually know what gon was doing six
episodes ago
or so when they split up so it really
reads to me who does many other things
in a week and doesn't remember
that far back like gone just left kilwa
got
into a fight with some people who wanted
to kill him and now he's sort of joined
the bug mafia i might be projecting the
bug mafia part because i really miss
that pursuited koala so maybe i can
wish him back into being i know you're
out there kwali i miss you
all in all getting to see kilwa just
flat out kill everyone who stood in his
path until he got to the octopus was
great so i call it a hundredth episode
well done
yes thumbs up from me onward to the next
century
episode 101 was all about killa and
honestly i loved it all
kilowatt is one of my favorite
characters and i think possibly one of
the most developed in the series if not
the most developed our favorite
characters and stories are really the
main protagonists because there's so
much information we get about them that
we can
imprint aspects of ourselves onto them
or at least that's why i think it
happens we identify with the main
character because we're supposed to in
some ways so it's left open that we so
we can
fill it with us which is why this show
works because it shifts the lens around
so much
and in this case the lens shifted
between two characters irkalgo
not an octopus boy and killer but it
also shifted outside them both to
continue that theme of narration that
highlighted just how alone kilauea was
in that cave
something we haven't experienced with
him in fact that he was alone
made the episode both heartbreaking and
beautiful because we knew he'd done
something to help not an octopus boy and
surely surely that meant icalgo would
help him in some way
the two narrated bits from the last two
episodes combined to create a
new chunk of information kilwa gets to
learn about how his powers work
more interestingly and more wonderfully
from my perspective we got to see him
begin to link his assassination
abilities with his nen ones
because to now a lot of what has been
happening seemed to be a shift between
the two the use of his men to heighten
his trained skills is a beautiful
harmony and
learning that at the point where he
realized he would die
was a great victory over both his family
and the doubts the character held so
long thanks to illumi's behavior
you know like stabbing a needle into his
head another special skill of quilos
is not just learning from what's
happening but sacrificing his body to
learn more while gone uses that
information immediately to
make a difference to his next action as
in everything kilwa is more considered
and precise
like his creepy not human hands kilwa is
a scalpel while
gone is a sledgehammer and it's
important to use the correct tool for
the job i do wonder as well whether gon
would have been able to deal with the
mercreature dartboard situation alone i
don't think he could have it would have
been an
it's a steamy affair because he couldn't
have figured out what was happening and
reacted to it impulsively and he doesn't
reign that way it required deep thought
and then it required enough presence of
mind to remember that if they didn't
think he was dead they wouldn't come out
of the water to check on him and he
would still be in danger from
some of the most annoyingly misogynistic
creatures i've seen in this show
he reminded me of exactly that one guy
at all the corporate drinks i've ever
attended and it was such a powerful move
for takashi to make them
so annoying that they didn't stop
talking even when their heads were cut
off metaphorically
it was great practically it was fun and
that's something that has been coming up
a lot in the most recent episodes that
we've sort of lost for a while i adore
drama give me intense psychological
thriller for months on end
constantly just pump it into my rooms
but there's so much to be gained from
taking the time out for absurdity to
come in and shift the
language and maybe that's what was being
flagged by a calgo
occupying a body that had a gun for an
arm and when i say absurdity i do mean
in the context of this show
the whole situation is absurd and the
chimera ants are sort of breaking down
the barriers between absurdity and
reality the longer the series go on
which is fun to explore and fun to watch
reality is morphing
and things that would have been odd
before like a talking octopus ready to
sacrifice himself in the hopes that he
reincarnates as a squid that's just
normal that's expected for some odd
reason that's now high drama
and and we can't stop it it's a shift
speaking of shift while keel was getting
killed gone's laying down some rules
with his
camellan friend who can't get a measure
of his aura
and we now have the two traitors to
chimera kind and the party is shown by
the outro oh yes i notice things oh yes
that i do
but back to keel while lying in a pool
of his own blood that surprises him
the calm with which he approaches death
is incredible the breakdown in thought
is realistic and the scripting is so
curious it was a beautiful scene i
reveled in the beauty of those
existential questions and bodily
awareness
as with everything else kilwa was locked
in an observer mode seeing things play
out in front of
and inside himself and yes i'm going to
use the word again that beauty and
special skill
is what killer has really not just his
ability to observe and question what's
around him and why but his ability to do
so detached from his own physical
experience of what's happening the voice
acting in that moment was simple
and clear and heartfelt and accepting
and real it's knowing and one of the
saddest things about it is that we know
he has to have experienced enough pain
in the past to learn to desensitize to
it even before the body dissociates to
try to protect it what we've had for the
last couple of episodes is
a killer unfettered by the effects of
his brother trying to stop him taking
risks
the result is extreme risk-taking and
this is the consequence now he knows
exactly what it feels like what impact
will that have on how he acts going
forward i'd like to know but i guess
to learn that we have to know if he
survives and that's not something i know
right now so i guess that's it from me
if you enjoyed the meditative stroll
through keela and a little bit of gone
click here here maybe here don't be
afraid to tap that bell hit subscribe
tell your friends and i'll see you
next time